i enjoyed your book about the lost city  and i believe you're the one who could  help me find its treasure what is this  taken am i took in oh no loretta sage is  missing i'm gonna rescue her that's kind  of endangered  alan what are you doing here we're here  to save you i'm certified cpr i'm  certified crossfit  i have snacks after them  we just got to take a little shortcut  through the jungle and we're good  jungles eat people like us what is that  get it off just give me a second please  feels like there's more holy mother of  god i'm like a blood jamba juice  we're so close i could actually find the  lost city  if i don't get to this island my friend  and her cover model are born to die i am  driving oh oh oh  oh  oh  [Music]  the red sage getting you out of here why  are you so handsome my dad was a  weatherman the lost city march 25th only  in theaters  [Music]